night Ron night
Ron ladies
ladies
you know what go din dashh out of the
way I call an ambulance a different
ambulance the one I ran into get on your
[Applause]
up and
it
on Tom I couldn't afford enough premium
carpet to get us to the stage I mean it
was a short walk but it was pretty
luxurious
right
okay everybody smile away smile
away
get up and make it
happen get on your
feet St leeding on my arm
[Music]
Andy
babe I'm holding the dog he is peeing
he's now peeing and I'm putting him down
Ronnie only has three
legs
scared run run there's no scares how do
I get to the
stage
[Music]
H
okay
okay ready
and Jerry God
gross
Jerry
guys oh god oh I think he might be
having a heart attack what are you
serious oh so much stuff is happening
right now call 911 okay just breathe
okay you're going to be fine no jeez a
dinosaur just fart Jerry get a grip
sorry guys Fu apology not accepted stop
talking I wish I could stop
smelling dude seriously Jerry did you
eat farts for lunch Tom Jerry's having a
heart attack oh no I didn't know that
Jerry you
okay go go go go go go go go
go yes oh my God that so hot it was
horrible I'm going to die I'm so
tired
everything hurts running is
impossible what are you doing Tom now is
not the time for criticism how did he do
Andy finishes two mile run in 29 minutes
and 43 seconds no I'm never going to be
a
cop I'm going to have to be a robber oh
come on hang in there pal I'm going to
drive
around Andy I'm proud of you not because
of what you did which was terrible but
because of what I'm going to be able to
get you to do I guess I'm proud of me
thanks man me too we have so much work
to
do
Chris I'm dying I was dying earlier
today and then I died now I'm dead I had
to cancel a date with shaa mway twep and
I really like her do you think she has
to like me now that I'm dead what is
this it's food
poisoning I have it too I did not sleep
for one second last night and I cracked
the bottom of the toilet bowl oh God
don't say that has anybody talked to Tom
I can't even imagine what that tiny
little man must be feeling like I have
voided more than Tom's body weight in
the last 12 hours alone he might have
just disappeared off the Earth we need
to call him we must reach out to
him I can't do
it
Ben extension
7820 you really shouldn't have dug that
out of the dumpster I had to also I had
a banana on the way over here sorry
and I get why you don't want anyone to
know about Duke silver and you don't
have to worry your secret is safe with
me to even it out I'm going to tell you
all of my secrets oh no that's not
necessary I once forgot to brush my
teeth for 5 weeks I didn't actually sell
my last car I just forgot where I parked
it I don't know who Al Gore is and at
this point I'm too afraid to ask when
they say 2% milk I don't know what the
other 98% is when I was a baby my head
was so big scientist did experiments on
me I once threw a beer at a swan and
then it attacked my niece Rebecca I'm
going to go powder my nose amongst other
things if you know what I
mean is she going to powder her
vagina
Leslie I'm
here we have to go hire a new PR
director for the health department only
my God I'm so hung over I've never been
this hung over I feel great I ran 5K
this morning
really no I threw up in the shower my
parents make me so mad sometimes just
like the time they couldn't decide who
gets the dog so they just dropped off
the local synagogue I was
like say
what hold on Ron hold that thought just
for a
sec hey honey hey uh it's your me it's
wife it's lesie uh nope I have very big
news for you oh well my teeth are blue
blueberries are alcohol you aoke I just
ain't around it my dog's
Jewish oh phone water Ben hello oh hello
hi Leslie it's dead
hello you know Leslie sounded weird I
don't want to wait for Tom I want to
walk home I'll join you I'm always game
for a brisk walk also if I leave you
alone I'm pretty sure you'll die home is
that way
watch out for that
fence okay so now you're sure that
everything is okay you know down there
you're perfectly
healthy that man has the largest penis I
have ever seen actually don't even know
if he ask mops forgot to look I was
distracted by the largest penis I have
ever
seen